hundreds of people here in las vegas are
now american citizens a naturalization
ceremony took place tonight during half
tame to half time rather at the las
vegas lights game it was one of the
largest ceremonies held here in clark
county in recent years madison kimbrough
was there tonight she joins us live from
cashman center with more madison
yeah people at the game tonight were all
in good spirits and it's not just
because the lights won those here to
gain their u.s citizenship are just
happy the time has finally come
[Music]
and it's a special day for our country
as we welcome them as our fellow
americans it was an eventful night at
cashman field during the las vegas
lights home game saturday hundreds of
people living across the valley had the
opportunity to gain their u.s
citizenship people like maddie who has
lived in las vegas for almost 10 years
and is an oh cirque du soleil performer
at the bellagio says gaining her u.s
citizenship is a way for her to follow
her dreams as a performer and she
wouldn't want to be anywhere else but
vegas it's a great city to live and it
changed a lot in the past 10 years i've
been here
i like our community and you know like i
love it here because that's the only way
i can do my profession you know people
originating from 84 countries around the
world took to the cashman field a moment
that for many say has been long overdue
it's been
a really long trip but i always dream of
this day
i just can't believe that it's happening
right now so i'm trying to enjoy the
moment i mean we had to live here as
residents for about five years and then
it was a lot of time a lot of papers a
lot of money
and uh but you know we're excited you
know to to contribute and to do well
in recent years with the kova 19
pandemic the u.s citizenship and
immigration services were backed up with
southern nevada candidates waiting to be
naturalized as the list continued to
grow
[Applause]
and tonight's ceremony lasted about 20
minutes and was followed by a fireworks
show as the crowd cheered on reporting
live near the cashman center madison
kimbrough 8 news now